desde hace un tiempo más estaba
surgiendo una serie de dudas y
cuestiones por lo que he podido
comprobar en mi entornos son de lo más
normal en la mente de una persona joven
que comienza a plantearse cómo será su
vida adulta
preguntas como donde quiero establecerme
de cara al futuro
para comprender por qué esa pregunta es
tan importante para mí hay que entender
un poco cuál es mi historia y de dónde
vengo
cuando era pequeña estudié en el cole de
mi pueblo en casabermeja todos mis
amigos estaban allí toda mi vida era
aquello
hasta que llegó la hora de estudiar la
secundaria la cual por decisión de mis
padres hice en málaga la capital de la
provincia
a raíz de darme cuenta de que mis nuevos
amigos y de que mi nueva realidad ya no
estaba allí empezó a surgir en mí un
cierto rechazo hacia mi pueblo ya que
éste no podía ofrecer todo lo que me
daba la capital por no decir que el
transporte entre casabermeja y málaga es
bastante limitado haciendo muy difícil
compaginar mi vida en málaga con residir
en casabermeja el relato de miles de
jóvenes españoles que por demasiadas
razones no quieren o no pueden quedarse
en sus pueblos
en mi caso no fue hasta bien entrada mi
vida universitaria estudiando el grado
de geografía y gestión del territorio
cuando pueda tomar conciencia de ese
problema
y es que los jóvenes no se van por puro
capricho los jóvenes se van porque la
vida que quieren para ellos es
incompatible con la que les pueden
ofrecer sus pueblos en muchos casos ni
siquiera se plantea la opción de
quedarse pues cosas tan básicas como una
buena conexión a internet un trabajo del
ámbito que les interesa o una atención
sanitaria de calidad son difíciles de
encontrar en sus pueblos además las
conexiones entre la ciudad y los pueblos
no hacen posible el hecho de trabajar en
tu pueblo y trabajar en una ciudad y
haciendo que la gente tenga que
establecerse en los grandes núcleos o en
su área metropolitana
algo que no favorece esto es el hecho de
que la dotación de servicios e
infraestructura se dé según la población
censada del pueblo y en lo anterior
contribuye el problema se acaba
convirtiendo en la pescadilla que se
muerde la cola
al haber pocos recursos la gente se ve
obligada a irse
al haber menos gente disminuye tanto la
demanda de recursos como la posición de
los mismos haciendo que haya aún menor
recurso y se vayan aún más gente
y ahora me voy a permitir una cosa ya
que como buena casi que ahora hasta que
soy me gustaría complementar mi charla
con una serie de mapas demográficos
mostraré a continuación y es que todo lo
que estoy contando cobrarán mucho más
sentido en el momento de que lo veáis de
manera gráfica y con datos exactos
esto es lo que se conoce en cartografía
como un mapa de densidad de población en
él podemos ver diferentes puntos rojos
distribuidos por todo el mapa cada punto
representa un kilómetro cuadrado en el
que viven 250 personas
llama la atención que españa sea el que
tenga tanto tan poquito punto ido a que
españa es el país de europa con una
mayor cantidad de vacío demográfico y os
preguntaréis que es un bastión
demográfico
un vacío demográfico es una zona cuya
densidad de población es baja o nula
vamos que no viene nadie
y es que este problema se entiende mucho
mejor cuando vemos mapas de evolución de
población porque todos los territorios
que el museo anteriormente se
corresponden con lo que llamamos españa
vacía que no vacía
como el chi mostrando ahora en el
instituto nacional de estadística
podemos ver la evolución que ha habido
durante estos años el primero de ellos
tenemos la densidad de población de
españa en el año 1857 llama la atención
que la mayoría del mapa este colorado de
amarillo y eso es debido a que si nos
fijamos en la leyenda corresponde con
una densidad de población de 20
habitantes por kilómetro cuadrado una
densidad considerablemente baja
a continuación tenemos la evolución
hasta el año 1920 donde podemos observar
un aumento generalizado de la población
pero también encontramos algunas zonas
de azul que donde decrece este aumento
generalizado se debe sobre todo a la
mejora tanto alimenticias como
sanitarias que hubo en la época a nivel
mundial a continuación tenemos el mapa
del periodo de 1920 a 1950 el cual tiene
una situación parecida a la anterior
pero también encontramos alguna
provincia de coloreadas en azul es decir
que pierden población
ya en el período de 1950 a 1981 donde
las cosas cambian la península comienza
a perder población y esto fue debido
mayormente a lo que conocemos como éxodo
rural el cual fue un movimiento de
población desde las zonas rurales hacia
las ciudades debido sobre todo a la
mecanización del campo haciendo
consciente una menor falta de trabajo
agrícola y también debido a que las
ciudades comenzaban a ser foco de
atracción y la gente iba a buscar
trabajo allí a sitio del país como
madrid bilbao o barcelona
aquí empieza el problema
a continuación tenemos el mapa del
periodo de 1981 a 2005 la imagen más
cara de todas en él podemos ver todo el
territorio que abarca la 'españa vacía
actualmente el problema de todo esto es
que el problema es que la población ha
ido aumentando a un ritmo vertiginoso en
los últimos años pero ésta no se ha
distribuido de manera uniforme habiendo
un crecimiento y expansión de las urbes
en contraste con un decrecimiento de la
población del entorno rural
esta es la españa vacía una españa vacía
que por desgracia muy poca gente por no
decir nadie quiere llegar
y es que al final todo esto se puede
interpretar como una cuestión cultural
una cuestión cultural de una sociedad
que no valora a los pueblos y que se ha
acostumbrado a que formen parte de su
patrimonio y no es que seamos personas
descuidadas que no valoran lo que tienen
ni mucho menos estoy segura de que
muchos de los aquí presentes pagan
plataformas de contenido audiovisual
porque quieren tener entretenimiento de
calidad y entienden que para que este se
siga produciendo hay que contribuir a
ello
sin embargo no los pueblos de la misma
forma pensamos que estén ahí estén o no
en verano nos vamos a la feria las
navidades las pasamos allí con nuestra
familia e incluso hubo gente que era
consciente de todo el espacio libertad
que tenían sus casas del pueblo y
decidió pasar allí el confinamiento
vemos los pueblos como algo que están
ahí y que siempre lo ha estado y bajo
ese prisma es muy difícil pensar que
puedan dejar de estarlo en algún momento
lamentablemente es una realidad que los
pueblos están desapareciendo porque como
sociedad seguimos confiando en la
inercia del esfuerzo que pusieron
nuestros antepasados en preservar a los
pueblos en vez de tomar el relevo de una
generación que poco a poco está
desapareciendo
y es que si no hacemos nada el problema
se va a agravar aún más con el tiempo ya
hemos visto la evolución de españa en
las últimas décadas veamos ahora cuáles
son los datos y la tendencia que marcará
el futuro si no hacemos nada
el saldo vegetativo es la diferencia
entre el número de nacimientos y
defunciones cuando éste es negativo
significa que en esa zona mueren más
personas de las que nace es decir no
existe un reemplazo generacional
como podemos observar en este mapa
todas las zonas que están coloreadas de
marrón tienen un saldo vegetativo
negativo en el período del 2010 a 2018
la detección de la zona correspondiente
con la costa y con madrid y su área
metropolitana
debemos observar abarca la mayoría de la
península y es que el problema de
despoblación es una cosa que nos afecta
a todos sí a todos y es que como podemos
seguir observando en el mapa este no es
un problema de unos pocos pueblos del
centro de la península es un problema
que nos afecta a todos una solución a
todo esto sería que la gente decidiese
volver a su pueblo de origen o al de sus
padres
pero sé que esto es algo más que bíblico
lo que no es tan idílico es algo que os
vengo a pedir a todos ya todos y es que
debemos de tomar conciencia de la
despoblación que sufre españa
actualmente sobre todo el interior y
saber que es más que necesaria la
cooperación de todos y de todas en la
lucha contra este problema
ya no solo por todo el valor que tienen
los pueblos y que han atesorado a lo
largo de la historia sino porque los
pueblos pueden ser una posible solución
a muchos de los problemas a los que nos
enfrentamos hoy en día a largo plazo por
ejemplo está demostrado con un estilo de
vida más rural es considerablemente más
sostenible puesto que nos hace valorar
más nuestro entorno y el medio ambiente
además todo el mundo sabe que la persona
que vive los pueblos pues suelen ser más
longevas y esto es debido a que cuentan
con una menor cantidad de contaminación
acústica y con una menor cantidad de
polución además de con un mayor consumo
de productos locales los cuales no sólo
son de mayor calidad sino que tienen un
menor impacto ambiental
en definitiva lo pueblo no necesita
hoy más que nunca
el pueblo tiene mucho que ofrecer
aprovechémoslo para finalizar me
gustaría dejaros esta pequeña reflexión
uno no cuida lo que no ama y uno no ama
lo que no conoce
espero que con esta charla cojáis algo
que conocéis lo améis y lo cuiden como
hago yo con todos los con los pequeños
que conozco muchas gracias
[Aplausos]